donc la chambre de l'instruction de
dijon vient de rendre son délibéré et la
chambre de l'instruction a décidé la
main levée et l'annulation de la mise en
examen de muriel bolle donc considérant
qu'il n'y avait pas d'indicés graves et
concordants laissant à penser que muriel
bolle et pu participé à l'infraction qui
lui est reproché ce faisant la chambre
de l'instruction reprend ce que nous
crions depuis déjà quelques mois savoir
que muriel bolle est innocente et que ni
de près ni de loin elle n'est concerné
par l'enlèvement et le meurtre du petit
grégory
donc c'est une vraie victoire pour vous
là c'est une très belle décision nous
allons en prendre connaissance
c'est effectivement une très belle
victoire pour nous muriel bolle et
innocente sa mise en examen
tombe et bien évidemment son contrôle
judiciaire tombe également muriel bolle
est complètement libre est innocente